entertain these guys are how much did
the Muslim religion have influence over
you I respect I have so much respect for
it because I respect anybody who says
what they mean it means what they say
and I feel like they're the only
religion we do I feel like every other
religion so wishy-washy that it doesn't
mean anything anymore time Andrew [ __ ]
Time come on brother come and uh join
the um
[Music]
don't worry we're used to it
is on the bus
silence react with kindness watching the
violence they keep up you see the
slander Us in the table they slander us
on TV as well someone please tell me how
Islam is still fastest growing religion
in the world cause you can't find the
truth or the battle concludes from a war
of good against evil and it's funny on
the news but you know the truth we don't
believe those people if one person
accept Islam because of you because of
your effort it's worth more than Holden
yeah this is your brother Abdul hawalda
from Dallas Texas I'm here in support of
the dean center it's a beautiful
organization Masha Allah in the US and
they have purchased a piece of land and
several building on it and we are
counting our brother and sister
throughout the US throughout the world
to be part of this magnificent project
it doesn't matter how much you give it
doesn't matter how much you they need
what matter we all participate inshallah
may Allah bless you thank you so much
so I'm making what you guys doing guess
who's here my brother Gabriel
Romario how you doing
yeah so uh we just uh finished some
training trying to motivate you guys by
you seeing us train inshallah get off
the couch stop drinking Coca-Cola you
have something up and uh all them sugary
drinks and get your body right get your
mind right get your Dean right that's
right what do you think how was you how
are you feeling Chicago it's amazing I
mean I think it's a different feeling
when you get to move right
like uh expose yourself to a lifestyle
that we used to have back in the days
right now if you don't it's like
lifestyle that you have is very
sedimentary actually it's just sitting
down it kills you not right yeah there's
research on that like the worst death is
by sitting down too much in the cubicle
all day yes
I just uh the desk the desk I mean our
ancestors used to be forced by lifestyle
to be active it used to be in Conflict
all the time it's different go home you
feel different your wife feels different
towards you know you're coming from home
I mean from outside you're providing
your testosterone you know High doing
what it means yeah now you're driving
two hours in traffic coming home you
don't feel like doing anything
your wife's complaining kids are crying
just repeat repeat they take a weekend
off you just go in a mall or going
shopping
sleep and extra it's a killer so what do
you what do you recommend for uh people
to kind of get this because you develop
laziness you're just now instead of just
being a lifestyle that becomes a
lifestyle so what do you recommend so
people can at least throw I I just say
man if you could just do 20 minutes in
you know speed walking doing some
push-ups at home that's like baby stuff
before you maybe get to yeah doing
something oh yeah you got to start
somewhere yeah but I think you need to
put in that high intensity yeah like you
feel different right now I mean some
people just show up they do power
walking I'm like okay it's good for your
card you know what not but I think every
man should be into contact sport
absolutely no doubt about it I mean it's
just by default we're all Warriors back
in the days right and now we're all like
outside
that's kind of what you get in these
days bro for the guys so you're good
what do you expect from this Saturday
that's why I try I try to give people
baby studs where people who man they've
been so far away from working out eating
right yeah I tell them look just eat
real food avoid fake food that's the
that's like the minimum you can do avoid
process for and then start doing some
push-ups a person who doesn't need one
push-up you know I mean start doing five
a day build up slow do something dude so
try push-ups a day 20 setups yeah 20
squats takes about like three minutes
five minutes left actually do it for two
months yeah continuously see what
happens I'll challenge anyone just do it
for a month okay see what happens you
see yeah and then start hitch and you
move to the next step start moving up
start doing some uh some content some
martial arts really important it's
different when you get hit you know oh
he's just uh people left the shadow box
they love to sing they like to watch
them but when you when you get hit
Everything Changes different even when
you hit a punching bag and it's pads you
know it's like ah but when you get hit
back
then it's a different story and that's
real life right people think they can
just throw at life throw throw the kicks
in the face you know it's just like you
don't know what to do you don't know
what and that's where you end up in
depression anxiety people start popping
pills because they don't not end it they
think I can just do do do and then when
it's done to you they kind of like how
do I how do I deal with this so your
mind starts playing shaytans they're
whispering and then you end up in this
like dark hole you don't want to talk to
anyone you don't reach out to anyone
yeah and you just suffer
how much would you say because you deal
with a lot of uh people who have mental
health issues you do counseling that's
your expertise how much of a role does
this play if people get involved in
martial arts that it helps them with
their mental state
yeah I think see the Mind influences the
body and the body influencing the mind
sometimes you have a weak body but if
you have the right mindset you can get
that body in right you start I mean
what's the right mind to the minds I
just got to do it stop making excuses
show up as a server show up start doing
stuff
um problem is when when the mind's
messed up body can be uh in shape it's a
bit more difficult you gotta but you can
still push
um
thing is
it kind of all starts from here if you
you can look good you can have a nice
body with your mind's messed up you
don't have your mind you don't have the
right knowledge in your head yeah it's
very difficult I think it's easier if
you have the right mindset
to change your body I think it's more
difficult to change the mind but of
course once you get going you start
moving
it works and that's why you need to have
like just Community Brotherhood as if
your mind's not right at least letters
can help you can motivate you come on if
you're alone it's the worst place to be
in yeah so what do you think get get a
partner someone who'll go with you
sometimes if it's intimidating to go
through the through the door of a new
gym or something right so you get a
partner maybe and go tag team together
um what's the problem right I mean with
Matt today we have
the brother was almost dead people don't
want to hang around people don't want to
spend time together
um it's like
he's like IO it's always
like you know you always he said always
when it was always them together right
these days like can you just call up
someone anytime he's like look man I got
a problem without any judgment without
like you can actually open after that no
women can they can always go their
sister their mother cry complain okay
it's good I'm not saying it's bad you
know like it's good that they have their
Avenues to come here but like us I think
we're having an issue we don't have that
that Brotherhood we need to have an
accountability partner someone I like
that you need accountability yeah but
now they just like uh as soon as you
like try to give some anushiha or advice
to someone it's like they cut you off
culture so the process himself right the
worst uh person is the one when you tell
them you know if you're alone he tells
you mind your own business repeat this
again this is such a powerful Hadith
said that the worst person the people is
the one when someone advises it doesn't
fear Allah they tell you mind your own
business
I mean because it's it's that's the
problem with with men with us men we
have ego issues right like you don't
want to seek help because oh my God you
know you're fragile you'll want to get
advice from anyone because you know it
all like you have tumblers especially on
the map you're going to get humbled with
money if you're not humble now someone's
gonna humble you know I mean you that's
what it is you know you think you're
arrogant I think you can do so I'm gonna
choke you out too you know
that's just the way it is you gotta show
up and you gotta be humble and it
doesn't matter there's always going to
be someone better than
above every person I know there's more
someone more knowledgeable there's
always going to be someone better than
the problem is people are suffering from
low self-esteem that's why they don't
want to shop it's like well I'm gonna
get embarrassed I'm not good enough no
show up man and fight and just be strong
and it's about the heart so what if
someone's gonna beat you or embarrass
you you only get embarrassed if you
actually admit their embarrassed you're
only going to get embarrassed if you
accept that embarrassment if you're
gonna be there being humble and learning
and having fun and just feel like yeah
man I got my back with but it feels good
right it's just the learning man right
it's all about the evil so we have to
kill that ego and just come to the line
it is what it is so we we covered now
the part of training incorporating that
into your life another thing will before
we conclude
how much does food have influenced on
your mental health for example you know
just a simple example is it basic for
anyone studies nutrition and who's into
Health water you know yeah the keeping
hydrated obviously but drinking the tap
water yeah and they're contributing to
the lower testosterone because of what
they put in not just the fluoride yeah
you know the white you know the things
that they're flushing down the toilets
going into the
um the water drinking water and then
this tap water has all these chemicals
toxins in there and that's affecting
your mental health if you say I'm just
getting one example not to talk about
all the process
that goes back to how important is
nutrition for mental health I mean the
basic principle of science is uh you are
what you eat yeah right so whatever you
put in there that's what you're gonna
get so as you said right now I think
it's personally from my research I do
believe it's systematic
people say uh conspiracy theory and all
that but just look at the research
that's funny because you know you got
accused the conspiracy when you show
your research and like that's conspiracy
look thing is men are being a masculated
uh as you said the water the food the
lifestyle everything is against
being a man against being healthy
it's when you're not healthier dependent
on things depending on big people
depending on depending on economy
it is what it is I mean people want to
say yeah this is rubbish just look
around actually you don't even need
research just have to look around just
be observed that's something that you
observe I mean are we we're at the
highest
level of Technology Healthcare and still
we're dying from obesity cancer you name
it why
literally in the world
uh in the history of the world we are at
the best moment when it comes to the
research that our Brokers they would die
now testosterone levels are the lowest
sperm counts are the loss
what do you want
is that when you when you said you said
that something very factual the um the
attack on masculinity and is that why we
see a pull towards people such as Andrew
Tate in the Muslim Community a lot of
men they really enjoy he has a lot of
things that he says and a lot of the
youth and people gravitate because he is
saying some things that
yeah it makes sense I said if I have
responsibility for something I must have
a degree of authority over that thing if
the captain gives orders and everyone
ignores him then he isn't going to go
down with the ship does he he is he has
Authority because he is responsible two
things are the same right and we don't
obviously agree with that with
everything you know I would love to him
I had him on the court I'd love to him
to be our brother and the dean and
Andrew Tate if you're watching we're
going to come see you inshallah to give
you another invitation because we can't
we obviously can't measure him according
to the current he's not living by that
yet I think I think he's attractive to
it I think that he feels there you know
yeah something and it's you know you
meet these people were like look if I
were to embrace any religion it would
have been Islam yeah and I'm always like
what stops this this and like just do it
uh with Andrew Tate and others like him
it's not necessarily just what he says
it's also how he says it yeah right he's
assertive
he is he commands confidence these are
things that are attractive to both men
and women
and this is something that we're missing
I look at the compare and the table like
Sonic
you cannot compare
and people are confused because they're
attracted to these characteristics but
then there's a lot of baggage negative
baggage that comes here people don't see
that and the whole bad boy called you
it's not about that people like bad boys
about that is that people are confused
because that confidence that confidence
is attractive what comes with that
confidence is all that toxicity and all
the Haram and all the things that they
offer so people get the Muslims get get
caught up in that they look at our story
and with all the respect some more
Community leaders and their same
brothers be nice we have to I'm not
saying not nuts
no one says don't be nice right it's
just that if you look at the process and
again we look at
this
it's the best best example imagine if
you agitate he started taking Prophet
Muhammad as the messenger who was sent
for him also right yeah I mean like you
know we can take things
Embrace Islam I mean like I was huge
he would go up like he said
he would just go and declare it yeah
right I'm living on almost like he's
like they start beating us and we're
beating them he's like going back and
forth when he went for um sorry too oh
Hijra he said okay whoever wants to is
his mother to lose her son come on I'm
leaving you know meet me just on the
other side you know it's like
is he arrogant no but he's not scared
right so you find like look at the
process and it's not about being always
me and the problem with these guys in
the red pill movement undertakes is that
they're always trying to stay on one
side always consistent on one way
and when they get called on it and they
have been called even by women I've seen
a couple interviews where they get stuck
they don't want to admit the process
them would go from strength to softness
strength there's nothing that's the
balance right
and establish the balance and you know
in truth and don't break the bus so the
processing in certain situations will be
super super tough super strong
and a certain situation super lean it
depends on the situation I think that's
a real man he's able to ascertain what
situation requires which response
so people I entertain others they're
going to get some things right and a lot
and a lot of things are wrong because
you don't have Islam Islam gives you
everything is a blueprint for life
Muhammad didn't get things on his own
it's coming from a relation to the
creator of the heavens and earth so if
you want 100 on how to act in all
situations yeah gotta come to the dean
yeah to keep it simple I mean entertain
these guys are
exemplifying some elements of the fitral
the natural male disposition that's
what's attractive right it's like people
go back to their nature is that as you
said the Revelation is meant to
fine-tune the Citra to protect it to
guide it right without the Revelation
the fitra can be corrupted yeah the
Revelation is a man there to guide the
fitra
remove the Revelation put on the
Revelation and find music
This Time Andrew said Time come on
brother come and uh join the ummah let's
go
um what would you say to him he's coming
in you know I would say stop messing
around like you know take your glasses
off sunglasses that's a sign of
insecurity you know he's saying that
it's his eyes and he's got some but in
the end you see him sometimes in the sun
outside without his sunglasses yeah you
know the Samurais used to always use a
mask because they're high there and
securities and fears you know that scary
masks right the sunglasses are a sign of
insecurity there's something missing
something is something that you can
never get no matter what you do you can
train you can be the toughest guy in the
end if there's no Iman there's something
missing and that's not uh I'm not trying
to like disrespect no that's a fact that
until God Almighty Allah is saying that
truly in the remembrance I love the
hearts find the rest so you can never
really be satisfied and happy until you
have connection with your Creator not a
trinity or not in you know worshiping
your desires anyone else so this is out
of the love calling you to what will
give you the security full of confidence
security and that's relationship with
the one who created you can remember
about that's right and the dean Islam
let's do it let's do it all right all
right so we covered a lot here we
covered the uh training make it part of
your regimen get in shape get active
start with some push-ups Eat Right avoid
the tap water right mindset get your
mind right uh and you can't do that if
you're not waking up for fudger in the
morning there's a lot we can cover a lot
of muscles but I can't lift the hand the
blanket you know they are good good
bonding here with my brothers
we need to do this for the future of our
children the future of our great country
the future of mankind this is your
brother and I've got a very important
message alhamdulillah our brother Eddie
is setting up the dean Center not just
the dean show but the dean Center a full
dawa Academy a Masjid a dawa Center in
America the first of its type the a
groundbreaking project and I want
everybody as I'm supporting it I want
everybody to support it so we can take
the dawah to the next level we need the
dean Center please support it
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedeenshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you and if you
like this episode of the dean show like
this video
share this video far and wide